i knew putin in two incarnations even in
that second incarnation he was brutal
but calculating
my anxiety is we got a third
britain's former prime minister tony
blair has met vladimir putin several
times and knows what it's like to
negotiate with him
tony blair sat down with the economist
editor-in-chief to give his take on how
the west should deal with the russian
president
he deserves to be completely defeated
this global but divisive statesman told
us western foreign policy has lost its
way
the wake-up call to the west has been
going on for a long time
and that western democracies must use
this moment to get back on the front
foot and shape the global balance of
power
tony blair thank you so much for joining
us
so what about the evolution of vladimir
putin you've met him and you describe
how early on you thought of him as a
reformer what do you think has happened
when i first met him we offered a strong
relationship with nato precisely in
order to allay russian fears that you
know nato was about encircling russia
then over time you notice that he was
removing all the democratic checks and
balances within russia
um
you know i was getting reports from our
intelligence people frankly i didn't
really take that seriously at the time
that he was accumulating the people
around of massive personal wealth and
the anxiety i think that everyone has
now
is that he has become so detached from
reality
that
you know you've got a a new incarnation
the the worry i have now with putin is
that he
is he capable of thinking rationally
about this in a way that anyone else
outside of
that
closed
bubble that he inhabits can relate to
the war in ukraine was a wake-up call
for the west
was it a wake-up call for you too or did
you see this coming no i didn't i didn't
foresee this but i think the the
the wake-up call to the west has been
going on for a long time so
even if we couldn't be sure what he was
going to do
the west in my view has been essentially
in retreat for for over a decade
you know this is this is a problem for
us and we and we've got to deal with it
so let's let's talk about this western
retreat there's lots of reasons for that
but one reason i think
that many give is that it is essentially
a legacy of western overreach
particularly the war in iraq do you
think that the war that many people
think was disastrous and illegal the
invasion of iraq has reduced appetite in
the west for
military intervention and indeed did it
embolden and strengthened vladimir putin
i don't think it emboldened or
strengthened him
whether you agreed or disagreed with the
military action
we removed san martin removed the
taliban in order to replace it with the
democratic process compare and contrast
that with putin
he went into syria
to prop up a dictator
there were chemical weapons used against
the syrian population by assad we we
took no action so i think that's what he
sees vladimir putin is rightly you know
his invasion has been called a crime of
aggression
but you know many people called the iraq
invasion a crime of aggression it didn't
have un sanctions you hear this you hear
that the west has double standards what
do you say to that i think what we've
got to do
is punch back very hard when people come
at us with this okay you may disagree
with with what was done but compare
getting rid of a brutal dictatorship and
trying to replace it with a democracy
okay you can say that it was a flawed
effort and and there were failures
attached to it but that was as it were
something
supported by the way by the iraqi people
when they turn out to vote in the
election compare and contrast that with
literally invading a country that's no
threat to you whatever the country
that's never proved any problem for
anyone
come on
what happened in afghanistan last year
the nature of u.s withdrawal isn't there
an argument that that could have
emboldened vladimir putin because he
thought he would get away with it yeah
sure it did but a point is we didn't
need to do it we could have stayed there
and we could have helped the country
over a longer period of time now of
course it but that goes to the point
right round the world you see this i
mean my institute does a lot of work in
africa
you see all over africa the the
influence now of of china and now
increasingly of russia
the west is slow it's bureaucratic it
doesn't work out how to build the right
relationships and yet many of these
countries would prefer a relationship
with america with western countries so
my point is a very simple one it's the
if the west wants to get back on the
front foot it's got to do a number of
things that really important and they're
all linked together by one concept which
is strategy you've got to have a
strategic long-term view of the west and
its place in the world if you do that
then all the other things can flow from
that you can get back on the front foot
again
can there be a lasting peace with putin
in the kremlin i don't know i don't
think the
no one no one's going to believe any
commitments that he gives any assurances
that he gives
and i do think out of this
will come
two things
one i think this will prove his downfall
eventually that's my
my guess i'm not saying will happen
immediately but this is
he's turned russia into a pariah state
amongst the west at least and and
and crippled his economy but the second
thing is that ukraine will emerge as a
stronger more independent
um state probably eventually a member of
the european union i would say
was president biden right when he said
this man must go
well he was just expressing an emotional
response look i think most people are
sitting there thinking
how can you do this i mean literally how
can you do this and when you the tales
of these atrocities and butcher and
elsewhere come out and
you see i mean
2022
on the doorstep of the european union
it's
it's it's it's evil actually but this
does have sort of policy consequences
because you can agree that
it's very hard to see lasting peace with
this man in the kremlin and also agree
that regime change should not be the
goal of western policy but what then
should be the goal of western policy
visa v putin given
where he appears to be you have to
both
um
ratchet up the pressure
and try and get a structured negotiation
and get an agreement that at least halts
the hostilities you know he deserves to
be completely defeated but i think the
longer this conflict goes on that
becomes extremely difficult so i think i
i find it very hard to see how you you
you make a deal now do you agree with
president zielinski that the west should
be imposing tougher sanctions
particularly the europeans and there
should be more weaponry more offensive
weaponry
yes i basically agree with that i think
you've got to toughen up the sanctions i
mean
the distinction between defensive and
offensive weapons capabilities at a
certain point becomes a bit meaningless
they need the ability to be able to push
back hard um on the
uh on the russians and
that i think
does require
tanks
long-range missiles
other heavy artillery
are europeans
insufficiently prepared to suffer
themselves for this i mean do you think
there is a sense of the stakes well
there will be
some anxiety but we all are going to
suffer
some short-term pain look europe has
come together in a pretty remarkable way
but we're going to have to go further
and the the the risk the principal risk
now is escalation um
because
if you can't find a way to bring the
conflict to an end
and it's clear that putin is going to
struggle to win this militarily
the question is how desperate does he
become what's your um assessment of
president zielenski and his um
leadership of this war effort and his um
ability
to you know harness in some sense the
spirit of ukraine so powerfully globally
you know this was a defining moment for
him and he he did something that was
both incredibly brave and
and obviously
um
extraordinarily powerful
as a
as a drawing together of people under
the banner of democracy
let's talk a bit about the longer term
consequences of this do you think this
is a defining moment
for the west and for sort of global
geopolitical
balance of power
it is a wake-up call for the west but it
should make us think very carefully
about what we need to do for the future
and that's why i say it's about strategy
you know we need to
build our defense capabilities
we need to make sure that we are
um
building our alliances the the
transatlantic alliance has got to be
revived made strong i mean really strong
we have got to have a
coherence of policy across
the piece so that you know those people
who are our allies
we're we're standing with them we're
helping them but above all else we
should have confidence
in our in our own system
and
you know we haven't you know the
politics of the us's in the last years
has been you know to be honest it's been
a mess and it's been a problem i mean
there is a you know a non-negligible
possibility that donald trump wins the
election in 2024. so can you be
sure about you know the us being
where it is right now in terms of its
position on
ukraine and putin look
we'll have to accept whatever the us
decides to do i mean these people are
elected but i mean i have no idea
whether that will happen or not or
whether he's even going to stand but the
point is whoever is the president
i i think after what has happened
whoever is the president is going to
recognize that they need to build strong
alliances you know irrespective of
what's been said in the past
so i'm not i'm not i'm not too worried
about that no matter what happens and
the second part of your your strategy
was um building the alliances more
broadly but if you look at countries
from india to saudi arabia to the uae to
large numbers of countries in africa
they have not been part of this
anti-putin alliance they have not really
come out in support of ukraine in any
meaningful way i think it's a spur to us
to think strategically
look if you're india got pakistan next
door to it it's got
um china which is a constant presence on
its border with with skirmishes you know
if you're india you need to build your
defense capability so maybe we should be
asking the question of
why why have the indians gone to russia
and not and not come to us and then when
you look at the middle east if you're
one of the middle east countries at the
moment you think your big threat is is
iran
and
are we really
helping stand up to that threat or not
and in africa
you know as i say the the fact is if
you're if you're in the sahel group of
countries
you see the these the russia moving in
there i mean the sahel group of
countries is a group of countries where
it's absolutely vital
for the west to be seen to act and to be
acting against this um jihadist
extremism uh and all the problems that
those countries have if if we don't act
by the way we're going to get floods of
migration from those countries and big
problems of extremism but we're not
there
so xi jinping is often thought of as
having a strategy and a much bigger
longer term vision for china's rise this
this partnership with russia now and and
the very clear decision that he has made
not to criticize russia does it mean
we're going to be in a kind of alliance
of autocracies or how do you see that
well again it's one of the things i've
learned since leaving office is how
important it is not to see this always
from a western point of view
and
you know from the chinese point of view
they
you know they regard themselves and
indeed are a major major power they look
after their own interests if china
believes that the west is
irretrievably hostile
and is looking to disengage to leave
china alone to put it as it were to the
side i don't think that's possible or
sensible but if they think that
then of course they've got no interest
in alienating russia because they want
to pull russia into their orbit china is
not going to allow russia to determine
policy i mean russia will be the
very junior partner in this relationship
so we've also got to take a complete
view what is our relationship with china
going to be that is the defining
question of 21st century geopolitics we
can't be sure
whether in the future it's going to be
merely a competitor or as most people i
think in the west now think it's going
to be our opponent and possibly even
according to some people our enemy does
that mean that you
think the west's current strategy
towards china is the wrong one
the west has got to be strong enough
militarily
to do what
ever is necessary to deal with whatever
comes out of china but you've also got
to understand that
divorcing ourselves from china not
engaging
is i i don't think it's either possible
or sensible you've got to understand a
power like china you've got to be
you've got to be in a position where
lines of communication remain open i
understand why you don't want economic
interaction on technology or companies
with a security
impact but other than that is it really
sensible for us to
to separate to decouple from china i
don't i don't think so so is this lack
of strategy why is it that there isn't
the kind of strategic approach that
you're advocating right now i think
politics has become much much harder
because
if you want to pursue a strategy
that's long term
and to pursue it effectively it's got to
be consistent
over a period of years what's happened
in in
the politics of the west over these past
years there's been this you know surge
of populism there's been splintering off
to the far right to the far left what
will it take for this ghastly invasion
and its aftermath to be the
catalyst if you will for the kind of
rethinking strategic rethinking that
you're calling for i'm horrified by
what's happening in ukraine but long
term out of this
i think
what's happened demonstrates the value
of a liberal democracy and it's also
will stimulate i believe a revaluation
from the west of how it positions itself
and my hope is within our internal
politics in the west
you know those that
populism that i think has done a huge
amount of damage to our position that
are standing
is in retreat so the long-term prospects
for liberal democracy i think have been
amply
demonstrated as as positive
i hope you're right tony blair thank you
very much indeed
thanks for watching if you'd like to
find out more about our forthcoming
subscriber events or watch previous
discussions please click the link
see you next time